i know
most people don't think about us up
there in the mountains
many of my patients are minors it's
dangerous work and
they carry the burden of building this
nation on their backs
they're thorough pain
these people my people
trusted me
i can't believe how many of them are
good now
we've begun looking at something that
could be big oxycontin
purdue pharma they've been marketing the
drug as something that's non-addictive
when it clearly is all your doctors are
gonna be asking how is this even
possible your most effective talking
point are these magic words less than
one percent less than one percent less
than one less than one told me that less
than one percent would become addicted
foxy cotton does what i think it
can we could soon become purdue's first
billion dollar drug
purdue continues to lie about the drug
safety
doctors patients and the fda
we have a major case here
addiction rates overdoses and crime
are on the rise across the country
because of this drug
i think maybe the medicine
might be just a tad more addictive than
you said
i can't live like this anymore
our community is ground zero for a
national catastrophe
purdue will not move unless we punch
hard
[Music]
this is not our fault these people want
to be addicted
i want top executives to feel some pain
it's crucial they understand we've
created greatest painkiller in the
history of human civilization
[Music]
i think i can make this the biggest drug
in the world
[Music]
[Music]
you